welcome back now is that time of the
year and that much loved song let's
listen to it
[Music]
snow is falling
[Music]
merry christmas
everyone
absolutely brilliant now this definitely
won't be the first or the last time
you've heard this song i did try and
sing it there and um the voice was uh
quite horrific so i must apologize to
everyone but shaking stevens the man
himself is here releasing one of his
most iconic hits available on vinyl it's
so good to have you here this morning
thanks for joining us here on sky news
my goodness it's not christmas without
you well that's very good isn't it
really uh for so many a lot of people it
does well in the in the uk it does well
in germany throughout europe and uh
uh austria
and uh yeah people just uh like it you
know i guess not all you can expect
everybody to like
your christmas uh single but i mean
there's quite a few up there that do
and the proof is in the pudding by
getting into the charts each year
absolutely no everybody should love it
if you don't love it why don't you love
it now if you do do a remix i just i
want in okay let me in let me know i'll
do a little duet with you so that i can
get some royalties to this now did you
think that this song will live on and on
i'm sure it will but it's been great it
was released in 84.
five i'm uh maybe five that's what ab5
is released and uh and here we are uh
moving on uh uh many decades really
basically and uh yeah i think it's uh
the thing is with this song for merry
christmas everyone is that it's very
uplifting
uh it's got uh great lyrics and uh
the start is very important it hits you
straight away and the verses go along
and the the the middle eight changes
and then after that at the very end you
get the repeat of for merry christmas
everyone and it goes into a key change
and then it's uh brass at the end and uh
yeah it's great it's fantastic you know
i've actually seen people listening to
it yeah even uh
and
and they love it you know i can't expect
everybody to love it but there's a lot
to do
well we love it here okay many of us do
and just tell us about the remastered
version then
the reva's remastered version well we
just made it more kind of
more punchy i guess yeah more punchy and
uh
we've changed the video just a little
bit at the front of it
but uh after that it's it's basically
the same really with uh technology you
know uh moves forward so uh it's more
punchy now uh than it was in
those years gone by so we're very very
very very pleased with the uh
the uh of the the new uh
master we certainly are
now do you think do you ever see
yourself bringing out a completely new
christmas track as well is that
something that you'd consider
uh again it really depends on the track
really but i think
the the radio stations have a policy uh
and uh i i think and believe
they i've made other uh christmas uh
tracks one that got to number two top 20
and so forth
but it's merry christmas everyone that
actually sticks out so if i i think if i
actually uh came up with a brand new
christmas uh uh
song
i would think that uh
merry christmas everyone the radio
stations would still be played
merry christmas everyone
that's true actually if it ain't broke
don't fix it that's the thing isn't it
and let's look just before we let you go
just tell us about how you're going to
be spending your christmas i mean do you
spend it's just sort of playing your own
music
well i i think we've got a full-on day
because with the uh uh with the releases
we've been doing and uh with the the
advent calendar that we've been involved
with as well and also uh many other uh
situations uh
the the
the box set that we had out last year
was 266 tracks and uh
i think they're doing uh a a lot more to
do with it
and uh so we're gonna be full on and uh
but uh i'm looking forward to uh to have
a
a
a break as well over christmas
with family and uh obviously i have to
be careful because of the corvid but uh
just relax and then get myself already i
am going on a uh
the end of the year with
status quo
all next year i'm told with the thumb
of next year uh the end of the year so
i'm looking forward to that it's a
christmas christmas time so yes i will
be singing merry christmas everyone on
tour
and maybe a few more christmas songs
and uh
so i'm looking forward to doing that uh
the 2022 tour
next year with the status quo
and
we're going to have a ball